welcome back everyone this is part eight
in our series on supervised sentiment
analysis the final screencast in the
series we're going to be talking about
recurrent neural network or rnn
classifiers i suppose this is officially
our first step into the world of deep
learning for sentiment analysis
this slide gives an overview of the
model and let's work through it in some
detail so we've got a single example
with three tokens the rock rules these
models are prepared for variable length
sequences but this example has to have
happens to have length three
and the first step to get this model
started is a familiar one we're going to
look up each one of those tokens in what
is presumably a fixed embedding space
here so for each token we'll get a
vector representation
the next step is that we have some
learned parameters a weight matrix w xh
and the subscript indicates that we're
going from the inputs x into the hidden
layer h so that's a first transformation
and that weight matrix is used at each
one of these time steps
there is a second learning weight matrix
which i've called whhh to indicate that
we are now traveling through the hidden
layer
so we start at some initial state h0
which could be an all zero or a randomly
initialized vector or a vector coming
from some other component in the model
and that representation is combined with
the representation that we derive going
vertically up from the embedding usually
in some additive fashion to create this
hidden state here h1 and those
parameters wh are used again at each one
of these time steps so that we have two
learned weight matrices as part of the
core structure of this model the one
that takes us from embeddings into the
hidden layer and the one that travels us
across the hidden layer and again those
are typically combined in some additive
fashion to create these internal hidden
representations
now we can do anything we want with
those internal hidden representations
when we use rnns as classifiers we do
what is arguably the simplest thing
which is take the final representation
and use that as the input to a standard
softmax classifier so from the point of
view of h3 going to y here we just have
a learn weight matrix for the classifier
maybe also a bias term but from this
point here this is really just a
classifier of the sort we've been
studying up until this point in the unit
of course we could elaborate this model
in all sorts of ways it could run
bidirectionally we could make more full
use of the different hidden
representations here but in the simplest
mode our rnn classifiers will just
derive hidden representations at each
time step and use the final one as the
input to a classifier a couple things i
would say about this first if you would
like a further layer of detail on how
these models are structured and
optimized i would encourage you to look
at this pure numpy reference
implementation of an rnn classifier that
is included in our course code
distribution i think that's a great way
to get a feel for the recursive process
of
you know computing through full
sequences and then having the error
signals back propagate through to update
the weight matrix
but for now i think just understanding
that the core structure of this model is
sufficient
i just want to remind you from the
previous screencast that we're very
close to the idea of distributed
representations of features that i
introduced before
recall that for this mode what we do is
look up each token in an embedding space
just as we do for the rnn
but instead of learning some complicated
combination function with a bunch of
learned parameters we simply combine
them via sum or average and that's the
basis that's the input to the classifier
here the rnn can be considered an
elaboration of that because instead of
assuming that these vectors here will be
combined in some simple way like summer
mean we now have really vast capacity to
learn a much more complicated way of
combining them that is optimal with
respect to the classifier that we're
trying to fit
but fundamentally these are very similar
ideas and if it happened that
some or mean is in this picture was
exactly the right function to learn for
your data then the rnn would certainly
have the capacity to do that we just
tend to favor the rnn because it can
learn of course a much wider range of
complicated custom functions that are
particular to the problem that you've
posed
now so far we've been operating in the
mode which i've called standard rnn data
set preparation let's linger over that
in a little bit of detail suppose that
we have two examples containing the
tokens aba and bc those are our two raw
inputs
the first step in the standard mode is
to look at each one of those in some in
in some list of indices
and then those indices are keyed into an
embedding space and those finally give
us the vector representations of each
examples so that really and truly the
inputs of the rnn is a list of vectors
it's just that we have typically
obtained those vectors by looking them
up in a fixed embedding space and so for
example since a occurs twice in this
first example it is literally repeated
as the first and third vectors here
now i think you can see latent in this
picture the possibility that we might
drop the embedding space and instead
just directly input lists of vectors and
that is one way that we will explore
later on in the quarter of using
contextual models like bert we would
simply look up entire token streams and
get back lists of vectors and use those
as fixed inputs to a model like an rnn
and that's a first step toward
fine-tuning models like bert on problems
like the ones we've posed in this unit
so have that idea in mind as we talk
next about fine tuning strategies
now another practical note what i've
shown you so far is what you'd call a
simple vanilla rnn
lstms long short-term memory networks
are much more powerful models and will
kind of default to them when we do
experiments the fundamental issue is
that plane rnns tend to perform poorly
with very long sequences you get that
error signal from the classifier there
at the final token and now information
has to flow all the way back down
through the network it could be a very
long sequence and the result is that the
information coming from that error
signal is often lost or distorted
now lstm cells are a prominent response
to this problem they introduce
mechanisms that control the flow of
information and help you avoid the
problems of optimization that arise for
regular rnns now i'm not going to take
the time here to review this mechanism
in detail i would instead recommend
these two excellent blog posts they have
great diagrams and really detailed
discussions they can do a much better
job than i can of really conveying
intuitions visually and also with math
and i think you could pick one or both
and really pretty quickly gain a deep
understanding of precisely how lstm
cells are functioning
the final thing here is just a code
snippet to show you how easy it is to
use our course code repository to fit
models like this in the context of
sentiment analysis you can again make
use of this sst library and what i've
done here is a kind of complicated
version showing you a bunch of different
features so
in cell 2 you can see that i'm going to
have a pointer to glove and i'm going to
create a glove look up
using the 50 dimensional vectors just to
keep things simple
the feature function for this model is
not one that returns count dictionaries
it's important for the structure of the
model we're going to use that you input
raw sequences of tokens so all we're
doing here is down casing the sequence
and then splitting on white space of
course you could do something more
sophisticated
the idea though is that you want to
align with the glove vocabulary our
model wrapper is doing a few things it's
creating a vocabulary and loading it and
embedding using this glove space that'll
be the initial embedding for our model
and if you leave this step out you'll
have a randomly initialized embedding
space which uh might be fine as well but
presumably glove will give us a step up
and then we set up the torch rnn
classifier and what i've done here is
expose a lot of the different keyword
arguments not all of them there are lots
of knobs that you can fiddle with as is
typical for deep learning models
maybe the one i would call out is that
we are using that fixed embedding that
we got from glove and i have set early
stopping equals true which might help
you efficiently optimize these models
otherwise you'll have to figure out how
many iterations you actually want it to
run for and you might run it for much
too long or much less time than is
needed to get an optimal model the early
stopping options there are a few other
parameters involved in that might help
you optimize these models efficiently
and effectively
in the end though having set up all that
stuff you call fit as usual and return
the train model and in that context you
can simply use sst experiment with these
previous components to conduct
experiments with rnns just as you did
for simpler linear models as in previous
screencasts the one change which will be
will be familiar from the previous
screencast is that you need to set
vectorize equals false and that is
important because again we're going to
let the model process these examples we
don't want to pipe everything through
some kind of dick vectorizer that's
strictly for hand built feature
functions and sparse linear models here
in the land of deep learning vectorize
equals false and we'll use the
components of the model to represent
each example as i discussed before